the Boy Scouts have begun admitting 3000
girls into their ranks 170 troops
nationwide have begun a soft launch
program after the organization revised
its rules in October this may make the
virtuous signalers feel good but at what
cost let's discuss that with charlie
kirk the founder and executive director
of turning-point us a fabulous group
who's also an Eagle Scout charlie now
I'm really impressed I was impressed
with turning-point but now you're really
cool okay so what's the problem with
having girls in Boy Scouts other than it
kind of messes up the description of the
group's name you know I always said
Laura I said well things are getting
really bad but what's next that I didn't
really let girls into the Boy Scouts and
yeah now here's where we are
you know I'll tell you here's what's
wrong with it social psychologists will
tell you that in the development phase
of young men in particular there's
something quite special and quite
important with being around just other
young boys as soon as you put a singular
young lady in that environment there
their behavioral pattern changes
completely and they try to impress that
young woman they tried their the way
they act the way that they interact
totally changes and look the Boy Scouts
have been unbelievably successful over
the last 100 years of turning boys into
men and creating some of America's
greatest leaders whether it be Neil
Armstrong or US presidents or US
senators and so I'm trying to understand
what with the motive behind this is and
really the conclusion I've come to is
the political correct virtue is
signaling left they like to destroy
things that work they want to destroy
core culturally that's talks it's toxic
masculinity now so you bring girls it's
less toxic I want to have you listened
to a comment from a father about his
daughter who wants to be an Eagle Scout
let's watch to think that my daughter
could be an Eagle Scout I want that for
my sons but yesterday I didn't know that
my daughter could be an Eagle Scout and
today she could if she wants to and that
makes me incredibly proud so he said
look my
daughters you know it's all it's
fantastic she gets to reach this
pinnacle just like the boys well what do
you say to the sons that want to join
the Girl Scouts is that okay now I mean
why doesn't she just join the Girl
Scouts just by the way is a wonderful
institution it's been around just about
as long as the Boy Scouts and here's the
real problem is that this whole move by
the Boy Scouts of America is going to
destroy the Girl Scouts of America there
is an institution that is designed
programmatically to try to have
leadership development for young women
and so that's the real problem here that
is it's going to destroy this other
organization just to try to increase
membership for the Boy Scouts hold on
Charlie we have a statement it came out
in October when this decision was first
made before it was implemented this is
Patricia Mellor CEO of the Girl Scouts
of green and white mountains services
Vermont New Hampshire to me a daughter
is not a matter of convenience you've
made the choice for your son based on
what you thought was best for him and
the daughter should be getting a similar
decision we know facts prove that the
Girl Scout program is better is a better
program for the girls and young women we
serve and it goes on and on about how
you know they're not happy obviously
because they think they should he's
going to destroy the Girl Scouts and it
will it will and look the Girl Scouts
already had trouble you know recruiting
and trying to grow their membership and
this is only gonna complete it's gonna
obliterate that but the broader point is
this and you see this happening
throughout our culture and this is such
an important cultural issue and politics
are always downstream from culture is
that the post modernists want to
redefine truth and they want to destroy
things that work and the Boy Scouts of
America for a hundred years has been one
core cultural institution that has
turned boys into men and now we are
severely jeopardizing that by inserting
young ladies into the into the Boy
Scouts and look I can't understand why'd
we just can't try to improve the Girl
Scouts and we have to try to put them
into the Boy Scouts and as an Eagle
Scout
as someone that has benefited from this
program personally I'm so disappointed
but unfortunately with the trend of this
country I'm not surprised all right
Charlie Kirk thank you so much